Por fin, después de más de 1.000
peticiones que nos habéis a enviado
hoy vamos a hablar de México. México es
un país que puede presumir de tener el
presidente más guapo del planeta. Para
los que había es este vídeo desde
España os diré que Enrique Peña Nieto
es algo así como a pedro sánchez pero
capaz de ganar unas elecciones.
Es más, estos dos políticos tienen
muchísimas cosas en común: ambos vienen
de un partido de centroizquierda ahogado
por los casos de corrupción,
los dos tienen unos índices de
popularidad catastróficos y los dos
intentan mejorarlos
a partir de estrategias políticas tan
descacharrantes que darían para un
número. En el caso de Peña Nieto su
última maniobra política audaz ha
sido reunirse nada menos que con Donald
Trump. Es la primera vez en décadas en
la que un presidente mexicano invita a
un candidato a la Casa Blanca que está
en plena campaña electoral y encima el
candidato es  nada menos que Donald Trump,
un señor cuyo programa político se
basa en insultar sistemáticamente a los
mexicanos.
Cinco días después de esta reunión el
candidato republicano subía 2 puntos en
intención de voto.
y os preguntaréis ¿qué interés puede tener
Peña Nieto en ayudar a Donald Trump
en su carrera a la Casa Blanca?
Lo cierto es que esté 2016 no ha sido
nada fácil para este hombre, en
septiembre ha presentado su informe
anual de gobierno cuando es el
presidente de México más impopular
desde 1944, así que, presentarse como
el justiciero que consiguió que Donald
Trump pidiera perdón a todos los
mexicanos
sonaba muy bien. Por desgracia el plan no le ha salido
como pensaba
pero la pregunta es ¿Qué ha hecho Peña
Nieto para caerles tan mal a los
mexicanos? Porque los anteriores
presidentes de México tampoco es que lo
hayan hecho mucho mejor y es más, Peña Nieto empezó en el gobierno con
bastantes buenas intenciones, en sólo
cuatro años ha sido capaz de aprobar
más de trece reformas políticas muy
importantes y tal vez esta sea una de
las razones por las cuales ha caído tan
rápido en los índices de popularidad.
Vamos a ver las dos más importantes
No es ningún
secreto que México tiene un problema
grave de violencia y narcotráfico. En
los últimos tres años han muerto más
civiles que en la guerra de Sudán con
Sudán del Sur
y no es casualidad que el sistema
judicial mexicano sea una de los más
arcaicos del mundo, está inspirado nada
menos que en la inquisición.
A diferencia del resto de países
democráticos en México no existen los
juicios orales, es decir al juez se le
entrega un informe escrito con toda la
información que necesita para
comprender el caso y a partir de ahí dicta veredicto.
Tampoco existe la presunción
de inocencia y por eso cualquier juez
puede investigarte e incluso meterte a
prisión de forma preventiva. Por
supuesto que a los imputados no se les
permite ni presentar pruebas ni
defenderse, lo único que pueden hacer es
responder a las preguntas inquisitivas
que les hace el juez y por supuesto eso
que vemos en las películas de:
- "Tienes derecho a guardar silencio".
Tampoco existe en México, es más, si
decide guardar silencio se usa en tu
contra.
Por otra parte, como no hay juicios
orales y todo se tiene que presentar por
escrito, los casos se convierten en
montañas de informes, cuadernos,
carpetas llenas de papeles, papeles que
se tiene que leer el juez para poder
dictar sentencia.
Así que imaginaros lo que pueden
retardarse a los casos y, por supuesto,
todo está regando con la salsa picante
de la brutalidad policial y la
corrupción.
¿El resultado?
- "Alrededor de tres cuartas partes de los
homicidios se quedan sin resolver y el
público se ha acostumbrado al
espectáculo de soldados enmascarados
que desfilan ante las cámaras a
narcotraficantes o sicarios,
recientemente detenidos para verlos
libres día después".
No sólo eso, más de la mitad de los
presos mexicanos no han sido condenados y
están ahí por prisión preventiva. Pero
es que, además, según varios estudios la
mayoría de los veredictos están
equivocados.
Para que os hagáis una idea, el 5% de
los convictos confesó su crimen porque
amenazaron a su familia.
Es decir, que en México me meten en la
cárcel a los inocentes y dejan libres a
los culpables.
Eso explica por qué el 90% de los
ciudadanos no denuncia nunca los delitos.
Por eso en el año 2008 el anterior
presidente Felipe Calderón aprobó la
mayor reforma judicial de la historia de
México.
Básicamente cambió todo este sistema
al que llaman literalmente inquisitivo y
puso en su lugar un sistema penal
garantista como el que tenemos en el
resto de países occidentales.
¿El problema? Que no puedes cambiar todo el
sistema jurídico de un país de la
noche a la mañana.
Por eso el trabajo de implementación le
ha tocado Enrique Peña Nieto y hablamos
de un proceso que puede durar más de
diez años. Sólo pensar en todos los
jueces y abogados de México que
prácticamente tienen que volver a
estudiar su carrera, por no hablar de
todos los edificios que hay que construir para
albergar los espacios para hacer los
juicios, los tribunales, etcétera.
Y, por supuesto, hay que esperar a
cerrar todos los casos que se empezaron
a tramitar con el plan antiguo.
Mientras tanto el crimen en México sigue escalada año tras año y Peña
Nieto, lo haga bien o lo haga mal, nunca
llegar a ver los frutos de esta reforma.
Pero, sin duda alguna la medida más
controvertida ha sido esta:
El sistema educativo de
México es el peor de toda la OCDE.
El 60 por ciento de los niños
mexicanos ni siquiera van a escuelas sino
que les mandan a guarderías, la cuarta
parte de los centros educativos está
que se cae a cachos, no tienen ni
laboratorios, ni bibliotecas y no es
porque méxico se gaste poco dinero en
educación - "México dedica más
presupuesto a la educación que España
o Suiza, pero el 93 por ciento se va a
pagar salarios". Para que os hagáis una
idea, el gobierno mexicano ni siquiera
tiene un censo con el número de
escuelas que hay en México, y todo el control
del sistema educativo está en manos de
los sindicatos de maestros, que son
quienes fijan los sueldos y quienes dicen a que gente hay que contratar. Por eso
la reforma de Peña Nieto incluye dos
puntos muy controvertidos:
el primero consiste en hacer que los
salarios de los maestros sean públicos,
transparentes y proporcionales al resto
de salarios de la función pública.
el segundo consiste en la
implementación de un examen a nivel
nacional que tendrían que pasar todos
los niños de México sin importar en
qué escuela han estudiado. Para los que
nos veis desde españa algo así como una
selectividad.
Pero este examen no es solamente es para los alumnos sino
también para los maestros, es decir,
que por primera vez se evalúa a los
profesiones, tanto para que entren a
trabajar como para que se mantengan en
su puesto y asciendan. Como podéis
imaginar esto ha puesto a los maestros
en pie de guerra, pero a un nivel
kafkiano. El año pasado se organizó una
huelga en el sur de México que dejó
sin clase a más de un millón de
alumnos.
Las imágenes que estáis viendo ahora
son de los profesores que no apoyaron la
huelga a los que sus compañeros de
sindicato les raparon  la cabeza. Pero,
esperad un momento, porque esto no es
nada comparado con las protestas de este
año. - "Al menos seis muertos y más de
cien heridos es el saldo provisional del
enfrentamiento entre maestros mexicanos
y fuerzas de seguridad en el sureño
estado de oaxaca y la lucha contra la
reforma educativa". Es decir que la
apuesta de Peña Nieto es muy arriesgada
y hay que reconocerle el valor por
haberse atrevido a sacar estas reformas
tan difíciles como necesarias.
Ahora bien, también tenemos que
reconocer que su praxis política no
ha estado a la altura de las
circunstancias, ni siquiera fue capaz de
evitar la fuga del chapo en 2015.
Recordad que se trataba del
narcotraficante más peligroso del mundo
que consiguió escaparse de la cárcel
haciendo un túnel en el que sólo
faltaba aire acondicionado.
Pero, además, hay escándalos de
corrupción que afectan directamente a
su persona.
Hace año y medio se descubrió que
el grupo Higa, que es una constructora
mexicana, regaló a la mujer de Peña
Nieto una mansión por valor de 7
millones de dólares. Poco después
el gobierno de México contrataba al grupo
Higa para que construyera una línea
ferroviaria entre México DF y
Querétaro.
Tras una investigación, Peña Nieto
salió culpable, pero en lugar de dimitir
cerró el caso con estas palabras: les
pido perdón.
Sin embargo, poco después de esto, la
periodista que había destapado el
escándalo, Carmen Aristegui, fue
despedida del medio para el que trabajaba.
Pero los escándalos no terminan aquí, a
principios de este mes de septiembre la
universidad en la que Peña Nieto
estudió la carrera, confesó que el
presidente había plagiado su tesis para
licenciatura. Por supuesto que él lo
niega y aquí nadie dimite ni a nadie le
quitan el título. Es más, su brillante
estrategia para mejorar su imagen,
aparte de reunirse con Donald Trump, ha
consistido en el lanzamiento de esta
campaña publicitaria de tan mal gusto y
que supongo  que los mexicanos
estaréis hartos de ver una y otra vez: -"Lo bueno casi no se cuenta pero cuenta mucho".
La pregunta es ¿todavía le queda algo de
capital político a Peña Nieto para
poder aprobar alguna reforma seria? Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios. En VisualPolitik vamos a
seguir muy de cerca lo que ocurre en
México con Peña Nieto,
así que si os interesa este tema no
olvidéis a suscribiros para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones. Como
siempre, si alguien quiere profundizar
más, encontrará varios links en la
descripción. Si os ha gustado este
vídeo darle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo. Un abrazo y hasta pronto.